lignes régionales privatiser ce serait
une première dans l'histoire du rail
français transdev une compagnie privée
pourrait exploiter la liaison marseille
nice
la privatisation l'idée sur les rails
depuis quelque temps en 2005 la sncf
engage des partenariats public privé
pour financer la construction de lignes
à grande vitesse les cheminots crient
leur colère et dénoncent une
privatisation rampante de l'entreprise
publique réponse du président jacques
chirac à la télé c'est une entreprise
publique la sncf et ça le restera quoi
qu'il arrive quatre ans plus tard en
2009 le transport international de
voyageurs s'ouvre à la concurrence des
entreprises étrangères comptent bien en
profiter
trenitalia un opérateur italien voulait
concurrencer la sncf sur deux lignes
paris milan et paris gêne mais ça ne
faisait pas peur à guillaume pepy alors
président de la sncf pour vendre plus
bas que la sncf il va falloir que nos
concurrents soient très très bons
finalement ces deux lignes restent sous
le giron de la sncf mais en 2011 pour la
première fois l'entreprise perd le
monopole sur une ligne étrangères
paris venise
en gare de lyon un train différent des
autres thello lancé par veolia et
trenitalia
effectivement nous adopter une stratégie
assez modeste pragmatique et déjà c'est
de dire que la houle sncf n'y croyait
plus nous nous y croyons pense en faire
un produit meilleur que ce qui avait
jusqu'à présent et ce n'est pas fini
c'est en plus tard en 2018 c'est la
réforme de la sncf parmi les mesures
l'ouverture à la concurrence des ter les
trains régionaux mais aussi des tgv et
les usagers y sont plutôt favorables
ça permet de baisser les prix la sncf
qui détient aujourd'hui monopole pense
que c'est une bonne chose va permettre
de faire jouer la concurrence et sandra
de cette ouverture à la concurrence ne
veut pas dire privatisation de la sncf
comme jacques chirac en 2005 emmanuel
macron la sueur à la télé la sncf
restera une entreprise publique malgré
tout ce sera une entreprise publique à
capitaux 100% publics mais qui va se
réorganiser pour asthme et mais restera
public ça vous le garantis s'il n'ya pas
de salut à gaza sion lui tout dans l'air
absolument ce sera dans la loi 100 % de
capitaux d'état aujourd'hui la sncf est
toujours une entreprise publique et elle
le restera même si elle perd le monopole
de la ligne marseille nice si
l'opérateur privé transdev rafle la mise
il sera désormais chargé de
l'exploitation des lignes et les trains
[Musique]